welcome to day two at Palm Springs
sounds like somebody's doing a little
grass cutting back there but we're gonna
take Maddie for a swim are you ready for
this I think so I think he might like
this one this blue one looks nice so he
doesn't really mind getting wet but he's
never been in a pool before so I'm a
little nervous
thankfully we've got this nice little
tiny mini pool which I believe is
supposed to be hot tub but clearly you
don't turn a hot tub on in the middle of
summer in the desert you have a good I
would never let you go you guys go swim
let him go home so scared
okay I don't want to let him go I'm
scared a lot of no I can't won't have to
that's a lot of milk
you
we finally ventured out and tried to
find a place that we can fly the drone
that's outside of the airport
restriction I'm gonna set this up inside
Wow because it's so hot outside it went
down three degrees what's the
temperature oh no wait
the optimal drone flying temperature is
104 well maximum actually he's on
different set for 45 minutes
hey gobble this so drum I'm all cuckoo
God isn't hot come to the desert they
say I think anyone said it
what's that mean I mean turning on well
Elroy
take off the liver this is cool okay
well now I can't see anything
we successfully flew the drone it's
about a hundred and nine at this point I
do not recommend flying a drone in that
heat because it could be potentially
dangerous but we did it what 16 percent
battery got some cute pictures and of
course we got some cool footage I was a
little bit nervous because it's so hot
so I don't want to fly it too far or
lose sight of it because if I'm not
familiar with a location or how this
thing is going to fly you do not want to
fly it over top of roads or anything or
anywhere that could be potentially
dangerous to you or most importantly
other people so impact this thing up
successful drone flying I definitely do
not like the heat
we had a very lovely last day in Palm
Springs we're heading home tomorrow
today was a really fun day it was the
one-year adoption anniversary that we
got Maddie so to celebrate clearly as
you saw earlier we threw in the pool so
we think that he did okay in the pool we
may try again tomorrow and put him in
the big pool because he think that he'll
actually be able to get out himself and
there's like a little stoop that he can
stand on so we'll see what happens after
we got out he kept trying just sort of
get back in it was a little bit timid so
we think that he liked it we're not sure
I'll see you guys later I hope you
enjoyed our drone and dog swimming
activities I'm tired it's 9:45 p.m. and
I've been wanting to go to bed for
almost an hour
this desert heat these killer hey Jenna
where we going I don't know our mom's
freezing oh I know your restart as a
video